there was a lot of years lean years
living in a rat-infested apartment and
my big tip is it's okay to be sad about
the losses and so I let myself 12 for 24
hours I will sit in my pajamas and I
will be sad about that rejection and
then yeah and I'll eat that as you and I
will watch that TV and then after 24
hours pick yourself back up and you keep
going I have a great family that you
know that you can you know piss and moan
to so to speak you know and and and the
problem is this is not an easy time to
succeed in so I think just having good
people around you to cheer for you every
day is the same for me man every day is
the same I do the same thing whether I
mean whether I'm up here right I'm down
here it's there's no difference you put
just you know you put your feet on the
same I eat Chipotle every day I work out
every day it's all the same and the rent
the routine is the same so just be happy
always out here
be happy neat Chipotle's be happy needs
a bully that's the success I mean a
super success bruh i journal a lot and
so I look back at good times I look back
at bad times and I know that I made it
through because I'm standing there in
this moment looking back at what you
come through really helps push you
forward but surveillance patience hard
work and the little talent mix it really
well together with a little luck make it
the right way and you're gonna be
successful anyone outside of you is
gonna tell you who they think you are
and I think that's happening in our time
certainly as a woman more than I wanted
to the true voice the true answer to who
you are is inside you it's going to try
and be patient you know you're gonna try
and breathe and and fill your life with
with stuff that's pushing you forward as
a person you remember how privileged you
are and then I think it sets us straight
and with privilege comes voice and
remembering opportunity and all those
good things there are a lot of people
who will take your energy until you
can't do things you have to have the
right people the one who see the best
things in you
you you know will tolerate the difficult
things but who you know like share a
vision and you will support you
[Music]